des milliers de vietnamiens entassés sur
ces rafiots prenant l'eau l'image a fait
le tour du monde et leur a valu le
surnom de boat people
à la merci de la mer qui a décimé la
moitié de leurs ils ont fui leur pays
après la défaite des américains dont
certains dès les années
les plus solides les plus chanceux
verront les coteaux
l'opinion sobis sorte mais vite très
vite d'autres crises en ethiopie yoga
francs au plus tard nous deux ça vient
de nous faire oublier ce drame
pourtant plus de vingt ans par la guerre
du vietnam les réfugiés continuent
d'affluer à hong kong en 1991 au plus
fort de la de saad en démon 64
mais qui s'intéresse en corse misera
tout enflammer inventé par la guerre
froide
tout a changé l'économiste ennemis
d'hier sont devenus des partenaires
commerciaux touchant à des erreurs
c'est le 2 sept
festivités
aujourd'hui
lynn pascoe
vivent encore au conte
ok dans des prisons d'auxerre
m
[Musique]
après la rétrocession hong kong est
passé entre les mains des communistes
chinois mais c'est toujours le goût de
l'amour ce qui donne son rythme à
l'appel
la solidarité
la population de vos plus payer pour
[Musique]
j'en ai commence l'épopée des boat
people
[Musique]
bani bangou
comme le père fonde lui toujours
redonner une dignité en vélo
qu'est ce qu'un camp
évacué juste avant la chute de seine ce
prêtre
[Musique]
les paroisses du centre-ville
voilà bientôt six on ne sait pas vos 4
pamela beger lassé par l'attitude
inhumaine des fonctionnaires en goguette
à quitter son poste au ministère de la
justice pour défendre bénévolement
passionnément les boat people
elles luttent chaque jour contre la
politique intransigeante menée par le
gouvernement et le haut commissariat aux
réfugiés des nations unies
[Musique]
et
dans le camp doha est raide et
295 aujourd'hui
attention n'avoir plus tôt sexuelle et
son mari vangu affamés suffisamment
désespérée pour risquer la vie de leurs
enfants
son macbook
à
début à tout
il l'est
un nouveau né trop jeune supporter un
voyage de 40 jours en mer
tam qui n'avait alors que trois ans et
de l' aventure après une jeunesse dans
les cons son frère coque rêve toujours
d'amérique
mais demain après neuf ans passés
derrière les barbelés
toute la famille sera en patriotisme
[Musique]
se rend tous les jours dans les camps
c'est un privilège rare
il y introduit à ses risques et périls
diamant pour le plus malade 1
pour les enfants
parfois les lettres que
il est avec nous
aujourd'hui la vie dure au tour de l'ain
ils apportent des cadeaux aux enfants
dont la plupart bourgogne que la
détention
monaco 22 mai les femmes s'adonnent au
22 août quand je visite le conseil de me
donner les libérer les voies à ce triste
souvenir comment tomber le plastron ou
autorisées par le gouvernement il fêtera
ses centrales
je suis surpris d'y admirer aujourd'hui
on a quasiment comme beaucoup d'autres
m
[Musique]
je suis allé vite ligue déplorable it et
thriller
le manque d'eau du cru devenir fou ici
les camps sont croisés dimension un peu
plein de chaque famille sur les planches
il y en a trois
c'est la ville a absolument tenu à
saluer se dispute tous du même tour
qu'ils parlent à leurs enfants mangent
clac c'est leur maison de coeur elle
même si l'on à droite et sourire de la
jeune moneinchon j'ai imaginé 240
personnes vivant dans une tune 5 la
chaleur ou dans l'eau et le froid
pendant l'hiver et une intimité ne lui
c'est tout c'est plus un effroyable
nous avons constaté dans les cliniques
dans laquelle nous travaillons dans les
camps que la proportion de maladies
psychosomatiques était réellement
importantes asthme maladies de la peau
gastro entérite la violence à
l'intérieur des camps était réel donc ça
veut dire problèmes d'alcoolisme
problèmes de dos vos problèmes d'abus
sexuels qui était référé aussi dans
notre clinique comme les gens vivaient
dans un espace très réduit
il arrivait que la nuit les enfants
tombent tout simplement de ces états on
a malgré plusieurs tentatives de vouloir
mettre des filets de protection n'a
jamais eu les possibilités de le faire
donc c'est une un traumatisme crânien de
fractures
et puis des choses beaucoup plus
sordides beaucoup plus difficile à
supporter pour nos équipes c'était des
gens les tentatives de suicide ou les
gens arrivaient récupérer des seringues
et avec du sang humain au descendu sans
même des rats oui pour certains même de
l'eau de pluie
s'injecter dans les yeux ou dans le
pénis des produits dangereux ce qui
provoque évidemment une septicémie
tu pouvais être mortelle donc venez à la
clinique en disant voilà j'ai une
hémorragie j'ai des problèmes les gens
arrivaient complètement cassé il fallait
les transporter d'urgence et l'objectif
pour ces personnes s'étaient outre le
suicide c'était éventuellement de
d'avoir une chance une petite chance
infime d'échappée de cet univers
carcéral
[Musique]
oh
à
vie si long terme et le cas presque dix
ans que j'y suis je suis très triste
souvent chanté soir de trouver un jour
un pays d'accueil
vraiment rien chez moi c'est comme une
prison tout est mauvais dans quand il
n'y a pas eu d'autre choix que
d'attendre encore dans l'espoir d'un
[Musique]
pour beaucoup la tante us les espoirs de
lendemains meilleurs
il se réfugie alors dans la drogue pour
se la payer
on vole on se constitue le cercle
vicieux commencent les critères qui
déterminent le statut de réfugié sont de
plus en plus draconiens un simple
larcins peut réduire les chances de
départ à néant
[Musique]
font de ces avant le 16 juin 1988 et
dans les pays du sud ottomanisme s'agit
c'était donc très serrée des fossés j
cox à fuir ce terrible angels devait
tenir le statut de réfugiés civils
donc ces pays d'accueil ont accepté des
centaines de milliers de personnes
fuyant le diable et dieu sait si les
ténè lt ils ont continué jeudi à la fin
des années 40 le maire fait le
gouvernement ni les retombées des crimes
si seul on est parti de ce jour kiko
arrivés sur son territoire non vie
serait plus considéré comme un des
fusils et que pas moins qu'ils puissent
mieux nous avons dû mettre en place des
procédures d'éligibilité qu'est-ce que
l'egypte unités
l'éligibilité c'est la procédure qui des
termes qui permet de déterminer qui est
réfugié et qui n'avait pas qui est
réfugié est réfugié celui qui a une
crainte fondée de persécution et donc
toutes les tous les vietnamiens qui sont
arrivés à partir de 88 ont dû passer
cette procédure et les sites d
mobilité je dirais comme tout demandeur
d'asile partout dans le monde et c'est
la raison pour laquelle je dirais nous
avons eu à partir de 88 beaucoup de
problèmes en cours mais comment prouver
qu'on est bien réfugiés politiques
menacés de persécutions et non pas un
migrant économique
les demandeurs d'asile souci mon groupe
que les procédures peuvent durer des
années
famille a de nouveau jeté
ils ne peuvent pas prouver qu'ils ont
subi des persécutions seule solution
l'eurotournoi la famille refuse cette
option peut-être par peur des
représailles ou pour ne pas perdre la
face auprès des proches restés au pays
condamné à vie
dans un no man's land juridique et pour
une durée indéterminée
ils sont enfermés dans le camp des isles
famille b demande rejetée émigrent
économique a décidé le haut commissariat
aux réfugiés
la famille d'accord vendredi et demain
dans le cadre du programme de rap
mais cela peut prendre des années il
faut d'abord que le gouvernement
vietnamien les autorisant
tantôt ils sont envoyés au camp
[Musique]
où les conditions sont légèrement
meilleures familles c'est demande
acceptée après des années de lutte
ils ont enfin pu établir qu'il était
réellement persécutés dans leur pays
d'origine ils ont de fortes chances de
trouver un pays d'accueil
mais en attendant et ça peut durer des
années
et vivent dans des camps ouverts
comme celui de pilotes pointe et sont
autorisés à travailler en
[Musique]
les méthodes du hcr du gouvernement de
moutons sont violemment dénoncée par les
organisations au gouvernement
qu'ils les trouvent arbitraire et
injuste elles soutiennent que le hcr et
l'office des migrations décide d
expulsions sans également examiné les
dossiers you can see bouvet imagine
jusqu'à l' fip d'ordre l'officier
l'immigration avait reçu juste où il
était dit avant même que la procédure
une inéligibilité soit mise en place
tiennent presque 10% léser personne ne
pourrait obtenir le statut dieng
officiers voulant garder son travail ne
trouvait jamais plus de déboursant de
réfugiés ces gens là viennent avec la
plupart du temps des histoires qui sont
fabriqué de a à z donc nous on doit
vraiment déterminer qui est sérieux qui
et qui ne l'est pas et essaient parfois
extrêmement difficile et nous devons
faire tous les efforts possibles pour
s'assurer que celui qui a réellement une
crainte fondée de persécution a le
statut de réfugié ce n'est pas ce n'est
pas un travail facile et ce n'est pas un
travail qu'on peut faire publiquement
une fois leur demande rejetée
et les vietnamiens sont violemment
rapatriés par les autorités donc
en tout plus de dix mille expulsions sur
lesquels le hcr est accusé d'avoir fermé
les yeux hcr bienveillant il doit au
gouvernement
l'équivalent d'amis
en français
de l'argent dépensé
du sort pour les boat people
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
à partir du début des années 90 je pense
qu'il ya vraiment une volonté de la part
du gouvernement de hong kong de rendre
les conditions de plus en plus difficile
pour pousser les gens à rentrer
volontairement chez eux donc diminution
des services avec un nom nettoyage des
camps diminution l'hygiène des camps des
munitions des infrastructures à
l'intérieur des camps
donnez nous la crise a fait exprès pour
obliger les gens à rentrer chez eux
les officiels leur disait civile et les
poires du gorille de gaulle avec la roue
tourne dans votre pays mais wang n'a
déjà plus le droit de former des comptes
sociaux et ce tant ils sont arrêtés chez
toute activité qui tient qu ils ont un
pc un service ou dans lesquelles des
gens avaient confiance en christophe
dessy dada certaine tout formelle du
qualifié des nations unies qui fête ses
dix ans qui s'est développée dans cette
affaire
[Musique]
révolté les boat people manifestent leur
colère sur les toits de leurs prisons et
rêve de mobiliser l'opinion
internationale en vain la réponse du
gouvernement sera sans pitié violences
arrestations séparation des familles à
certains hommes ont grimpé sur les toits
et ont sauté prirent pour protester
contre les rapatriements
[Musique]
ils ont tiré des gaz lacrymogènes dans
les complaintes femmes et d'enfants
c'était pouvait plus respirer parler
tout le monde est reine c'était la
panique
[Musique]
les gens ont mis le feu à une rue
ils allaient être rapatriés
il mettait le feu pour protester contre
la violence de la police
[Musique]
ils ont tenté leur chance pour la
liberté n'est fait mais ils ont échoué
puis sont devenus très dépressive être
déçu sans plus aucun espoir dans
l'avenir dont l'internement et ne faut
pas oublier que c'était des innocents et
certains autres ne pouvons pas supporter
se stressant sont arrivés au suicide par
exemple donc en de taisho deux jeunes
filles se sont tendues à cause du stress
des procédures de l'égibilité les gens
devaient à d'autres plus de trois ans
avant d'être le gouvernement leur disais
vous n'êtes pas réfléchi rentrez chez
vous 7-8 ans dans les camps de détention
finalement s'entendre dire vous devez
rentrer chez vous
[Musique]
condamnait revenir au pays les 300
derniers pensionnaires de white raid
résigné pèsent leurs bagages mince
fortune pour une nouvelle durée
le seul réconfort vient du père vang le
vietnam vaut mieux que les camps
explique le prêtre
mais après des années d'internement ce
départ
[Musique]
mais sa forme c'est qu'ils sont très
déçu d'avoir échoué vers de se retrouver
lui le blizzard auparavant je sais
qu'ils sont très tristes d'asthme nature
la plupart d'entre nous un joie
et c'est mieux pour d'autres et maloney
ont tant de fois je dis aux français
plus tard
[Musique]
la famille on s'apprête à quitter
whiteread les dernières heures sont
certainement les plus présentes les plus
pénibles
les gaulois ne fane et basés ici à
attendre pour rien le retour vous
utilisez des personnes qui fuit le pays
pas d'estimer ce sujet contre être la
patrie et serait plus alors j'avais peur
mais maintenant que le vietnam s'est
largement ouvert vers l'extérieur et
considère deux autres pays comme des
amis je pense que le jeu serait bien
accueillie et que je ressemble alors
nous serons de nouveau réunis dans un
esprit de liberté
le sentiment second front le coeur pour
eux quelquefois on était déprimé à bout
de nerfs quand on voit ce que tout ce
temps passé dans le camp nou semblait
tout à fait inutile
[Musique]
nous autres qui avons vécu dans des
conditions très difficiles
nous avons obtenu des résultats tout à
fait inverse de ce que nous attendions
de ce que nous espérions nous sommes
déçus nous sommes profondément triste
nous avons tous perdu quelques photos
jaunies gondoler par l'eau demain c'est
tout ce qui reste du vietnam à la
famille wang
les souvenirs sont là bien sûr il obsède
même quand on pense aux filles son frère
laisse aux pays d'où ils le petit
dernier abandonné au vietnam pour ne pas
éveiller les soupçons de la famille a
été élevée par ses grands parents
[Musique]
la situation de ma famille durant la
période qui a précédé notre départ pour
ma gang
c'est un rendez le départ de est
impossible
nous en avons beaucoup souffert nous
nous sentions coupable non fautif ont
ouvert cet enfant
énormément
mais après l'interview un missile j'ai
dû me résigner
je suis tellement triste commando il le
fils délaissé accueillera-t-il la
famille qu'il abandonnait le père jeunes
réunis une dernière fois les fidèles il
ne reverra sans doute plus il tente de
les rassurer
après toutes ces années d'incarcération
les boat people ou perdu pied avec la
réalité l'extérieur et piette au vietnam
une amnistie a été votée mais le haut
commissariat aux réfugiés que les abords
d'un prévenu tout ce temps les protégera
t-il contre des persécutions toujours
possible
le prêtre se préoccupe du sort des
enfants puis passe on est ici dans les
camps la détention l'a jamais ce petit
garçon depuis huit ans et ça y est ça l
a guidé les forains envers leur vie et
ils n'ont rien connu d'autre que des
barrières
[Musique]
blake était passé
ces enfants j avais que 2000 de joie à
travers ces mêmes causes ont donné vie
juste juste pour qu'ils aient quelque
chose à ma fille j'ai beaucoup
d'expérience aux enfants qui sont nés et
ont grandi dans la east
ils ne savent rien du monde réel je me
souviens d'un enfant qui vit de la
mission de les faire un tour de la ville
en bus qui était revenu au camp est de
dix ans à ses parents qu'il avait vu un
énorme raz en fait il décrivait un chien
n'avait jamais vu un chien service
il n'avait jamais rien vu d'autre dans
le creux des reins
[Musique]
il
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
on a fait faire des dessins des enfants
plusieurs thèmes qu'ils illustrent leurs
pires cauchemars et là des dessins je
pense d'une rare violence
mais il faut pas être psychologue pour
comprendre qu'un enfant qui naît dans
ses camps dans cet environnement où de
jeunes adolescents qui arrive en ayant
fui le vietnam ces jeunes ont déjà
l'arrivée des traumatismes sérieux parce
qu'on ne s'embarque pas dans un petit
bateau dans une frêle embarcation au
milieu de la mer de chine
il faut pas oublier quand même pas mal
de gens ont été assassinés
d'autres ont été violées par des pirates
ont été rançonnés par des pirates et on
la traverse et l' angoisse de la mort
l'angoissent de dérivés à jamais sous un
soleil de plomb sans eau sans nourriture
donc ces jeunes sont déjà arrivés avec
des traumatismes sévères à l'intérieur
des camps et les conditions des tensions
n'améliore pas c'est cet état de fait il
faut aussi savoir que ses enfants ne
connaissaient que l'univers carcéral et
donc pendant une période très courte
période des enfants aient la possibilité
de sortir du camp mais sous surveillance
de 10 garde donc des groupes d'une
vingtaine d'enfants sous haute
surveillance comme si c'étaient des
criminels alors qu'il n'était pas
criminel pouvait un petit peu se balader
sur l'herbe et c'était très révélateur
de voir des enfants n'avait jamais eu de
contacts avec de l'herbe avec du gazon
c'était une matière qui ne connaissait
pas
il avait des difficultés de marcher
dessus parce que les troubles étaient
réels bon et puis comme tout enfant il
s'adapter mais ça explique comme les
traumatismes
on ne vit pas non au milieu des barbelés
au milieu du béton d'une manière normale
[Musique]
et puis il faut se mettre un peu à la
place de gamin quand on discute avec des
gamins et qui regarde à travers les fils
barbelés
la ville de hong kong avec toutes ces
facilités que le boeuf n'y ont pas droit
c'est difficile de leur expliquer
pourquoi
[Musique]
yahoo
4 heures du matin
[Musique]
oh
vous savez convaincre et vols de
rapatriement volontaire c'est les
retours le retour et nicaise coffie pour
la plupart d'entre eux cette décision de
rentrer au et namor été un choix ultime
vraiment quelque chose de dramatique
parce que c'était rentrer chez soi avec
la défaite finalement comment justifier
auprès de sa famille son échec
comment justifier son retour au vietnam
on a tenté le tout pour le tout on a
risqué sa vie on a risqué sa santé pour
au bout du compte après 5 à 10 ans
prison vont rentrer chez soi c'est
difficile à faire accepter
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la série
[Musique]
on n'appelait jamais les vietnamiens par
leur nom c'était toujours des numéros
lorsque les gens étaient rapatriés on
les attache et on les veut dire on est
un fixe et un numéro sur leurs chevilles
ou sur leur poignet comme du bétail et
on est traité comme du bétail jusqu'au
moment il était dans l'avion et puis
après le problème était résolu et il ya
un manque totale d'humanité par rapport
à ces gens là c'est ce côté d
humanisation était réelle dans les camps
[Musique]
je pense qu'en tant que citoyens
responsables on a la chance de vivre
dans un pays démocratique et on ne peut
pas accepter ce genre de méthode il ya
le respect de l'individu c'est quand
même une chose essentielle c'est
certainement essentiel pour une
organisation humanitaire mais je pense
que les états devraient pas oublier
aussi que c'est quand même la valeur
centrale de la société via hong kong
[Musique]
une des incitants financiers à un moment
je pense que le hcr avait proposé 180
hong kong dollars pour chaque réfugié
qui désiraient rentrée mais c'était une
somme complètement dérisoire par rapport
à ce que ces réfugiés avaient payé pour
passer du vietnam
anggun avec les passeurs c'est difficile
à accepter
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
le regard de vitamine est assez
inoubliable sur le sujet parce que je
trouve que toute la détresse
transparaissait bien dans le regard
5 10 ans d'espoir pour certains qui
allait s'évanouir en 24 48 heures et un
retour à zéro avec cet inconnu que
cheveux roux vietnam que viège de venir
quelle sera la possibilité de
réinsertion et ça c'était c'était
difficile
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour les prisonniers cette dernière est
souvent première traverse
ils n'ont jamais 2,6
il se métisse
et
[Applaudissements]
oh
le mieux
[Musique]
je
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'argent
bien sûr on a dit à ce qu'ils reviennent
le vietnam a énormément changé la
société plus ouverte
les conditions de vie se sont améliorées
tous ont du mal à le croire
le progrès a certainement dû oublier
n'est nommément la petite ville de
province d'où est originaire la famille
mois
[Musique]
dans la maison familiale qui étaient
neuf ans plus tôt le grand père
prenons et dont le fils abandonné
attendent
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les dernières heures
vas y sont épuisantes
ce sont les plus longues
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
chaque fois que je pensais à eux que je
regardais leurs photos ça me faisait
pleurer je les aime tellement non à
l'horizon mais pour moi qu'il y ait ou
non un an justin n'est pas le plus
important
l'essentiel c'est d'être ensemble et
selon mr dans la misère j'ai mis sept
enfants au monde il est parti sans dire
un mot
plusieurs années de séparation du nombre
de mains et de quelques heures nous
serons dès maintenant que nous
approchons des dégâts nous ressentons
une émotion très forte à l'idée de serre
on t il
ni s'ils veulent partir ils partent est
ce que tu peux faire je n'ai su que lens
comme l'a dit les pires au dollar mais
j'étais maudit parce que j'avais élevé
qu'à payer l'école manoury concernant
notre retour au vietnam et je n'arrive
pas à imaginer ce qui nous attend mais
en train lexique de 180 boutiques de
temps passait des cylons les allemands
par l'homme donc je ne sais pas ce que
nous allons faire donc la vie vous
pouvez agir les palourdes à la personne
depuis qu'ils sont beaux mais j'attends
avec impatience le retour que je
souhaite et on va revenir
parfois quand j'y pense mais à bien y
réfléchir je pense que c'était bien pour
l'avenir de l'infernal qui ne sont pas
vraiment partie qu'elle revienne ça ne
me fait ni chaud ni froid je n'ose pas
imaginer comment il peut à tout moment
comment il a pu changer je l'enverrai je
sens le telle menace mena
quand ils vont arriver la première chose
que je ferai c'est de courir vers moi je
les appellerai par moment comme avant
tokyo depuis j'en vois ton coeur je le
sens à mes ballets très nerveux
excité overstreet paris
[Musique]
dutra je voulais aussi des endroits qui
sont restés
[Musique]
il
une
[Musique]
tous
c
[Musique]
où
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le vietnam avait exigé que les gens
retournent dans l'endroit nous était
parti c'est à dire où ils avaient leur
dernière adresse au vietnam ce qui est
un avantage de faire que quand ces gens
retournent ils retournent dans leurs
villages d'origine où la plupart du
temps il m'avait encore une soeur un peu
frères la grammaire l'oncle attentes et
donc quand ils arrivent dans leur
village la famille obligée de les deux
les reprends donc ils ont plus leur
maison mais ils sont reçus par pas par
leur famille au sens élargi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quand les gens rentrent ici c'est vrai
que c'est difficile
il recommence à zéro moins que zéro
enfin il faut qu'ils retrouvent leur
propre l'habitation qui trouvent un
travail qui trouve des revenus réguliers
et ça évidemment c'est pas c'est pas
facile
[Musique]
une femme qui a vécu pendant cinq six
ans dans l'est comme un conte qu'elle a
perdu l'habitude d'aller en marche et
elle a perdu l'habitude de faire la
cuisine la maintenant elle se retrouve
là et elle doit reprendre une vie
normale et c'est pas facile
il peut y avoir des gens qui disent oui
mais voilà à eux sont les traîtres au
pays ils sont partis et maintenant la
communauté internationale lors dun 240
dollars moi je suis resté ici à planter
le rien comme ça pendant pendant des
années et puis et puis j'ai rien
donc si vous voulez la la jalousie
d'aider des gens qui sont restés existe
c'est évident mais c'est aussi très très
complexe parce qu'ils savent combien
aisance et pas un secret qu'ils
reçoivent 240 et ils peuvent recevoir
quelque chose en retour
alors en fait la communauté
internationale par l'intermédiaire du
hcr à financer des petits projets
d'intégration locale dont l'enveloppé de
3 millions de dollars par année les
écoles des ponts d un morceau de route
pour limiter cette tension avec la
population locale
le premier jour s'est bien passé pour
l'avenir on verra plus tard quand le
forez sera retombée se poseront alors de
nouvelles questions pour une nouvelle
vie trouver un travail une maison une
école subsiste un doute
le haut commissariat aux réfugiés est il
réellement prêts à les protéger
le fait qu'on ait été l'un permis que
tout se passe bien
les autorités maintiennent nous sommes
pas de raison de de vouloir persécutés
ces gens là je crois que le vietnam
à d'autres problèmes que ceux s'occupait
de ses 110 mille personnes mais dans un
pays de 77 millions d'habitants on a eu
très peu de nouvelles du suivi le
discours officiel c'est de dire tout va
bien j'ai effectivement rencontré aussi
quelques vietnam et à hanoï ça se
passait bien pour eux mais c'est pas
révélateur et je pense qu'il ya eu de
grosses carences dans le suivi des
vautours nice au vietnam et ce n'est pas
avec we moniteur qu'on peut s' assurer
le suivi de dizaines de milliers de
personnes
quand il avait été décidé que le hcr
devrait s'assurer que la demie ch'ti
serait respectée il n'a jamais été
décidé que le cerf devrait voir
individuellement tous les gens par
définition ces gens là ne sont pas des
réfugiés politiques
donc c'est vraiment un filet de sécurité
il est bien évident que pourrait avoir
plus de fonctionnaires ça coûte quand
même très cher à la communauté
internationale
[Musique]
la lame
c'est la première fois que le pays
tourne avec toute la famille mon plus
jeune âge je n'ai jamais la seconde à
être réunis après sept ans de séparation
mais il y en a
[Musique]
je pense qu'avec l'aide à ogier de
fatigue du hcr et de la communauté
européenne un accord avec lui en
programme de rapatriement bollement nous
serons en mesure de construire la
victoire nous a dit que des préparatifs
pour le voyage à hong kong avait oublié
un souci ils sont rationnées pendant
qu'au retour de hong kong king mater
baldé cela me donne de la confiance
beaucoup de confiance
de la force beaucoup de force la dr et
du courage et miniers pour nous pour
notre famille t'es con notre avenir
[Musique]
e
hong kong la perle de l'asie une ville
ivre de croissance sa fortune a été
bâtie tout au long du siècle par des
réfugiés fuyant la chine des réfugiés
qui se protège aujourd'hui d'une
invasion vietnamienne
évidemment si on compare ce chiffre avec
le nombre total de la main qui sont
venus à hong kong
on peut dire que c'est un succès donc
nous sommes finalement très satisfait de
la façon dont se termine ce programme
même si
même si on voit la m il y à certains cas
pour lesquels nous n'avons pas été en
mesure de trouver des solutions
de quel droit peut-on parler de réussite
si la réussite consiste à dire on a pu
rapatriés volontairement x milliers de
personnes ou de manière forcée x
milliers de personnes et biens très bien
mais c'est pas une réussite humaine
c'est sa peine une réussite statistiques
et en tant qu'organisation humanitaire
on n'est pas là pour faire des
statistiques et derrière chaque famille
s'est cassé cacher une tragédie alors
certains ont eu effectivement la chance
de pouvoir rejoindre l'europe la chance
de pouvoir rejoindre les états unis
l'australie le canada et se refaire une
vie mais à côté de ça combien combien de
personnes n'ont pas été brisée et on
sait que la réponse est élevé donc quand
on parle de réussite je pense que le
terme est très mal choisi
6 à tous les pays d'accueil sont
concertés et si je d'ici à quelques mois
il disait elle cède au final prenant
chacun de mes deux industriels
le problème serait résolu dans l'ariège
de terrain et c'est un manque de volonté
politique
[Musique]
tam s'est adapté très vite elle se
prépare aujourd'hui à l'adolescence
vietnamienne noc qui a appris l'anglais
dans les camps va tenter sa chance assez
égaux il rêve de devenir interprète avec
leurs primes
les parents au vient d'acheter une
petite boutique dans la rue principale
cette fois nous y restera leur côté
doucement
la vie reprend ses droits doucement la
vie continue
[Musique]
là-bas le camp de raï landes est encore
au vert le drame des boat people n'est
pas achever les derniers témoins
désespère toujours derrière les barbelés
donc on
[Musique]
i